Prof: Okay,
so this is what we looked at
last time.
We looked at an acid-base
reaction from a new point of
view, from the point of view of
bringing up some HOMO to overlap
with this unusually low LUMO.
Why is it unusually low,
the LUMO, σ*,
of H-F?
Why is it unusually low?
Is the overlap bad?
<<Students speak over one
another>>
Prof: Does the hybrid
orbital on fluorine and the
s orbital on hydrogen,
does that have bad overlap,
or does it overlap well?
Points right at it,
good overlap.
So that's not the reason it's
unusual.
What's the reason that the
energy of this vacant orbital is
unusual?
Dana?
Student:  The unusual
atomic energy of fluorine?
Prof: Right,
because fluorine started very
low;
so that went down,
when it mixed with hydrogen.
Hydrogen went up,
but it didn't go up very far,
because the energy match was
bad.
So that's this LUMO,
the unfavorable combination of
fluorine and hydrogen.
Which is it big on,
hydrogen or fluorine,
the one that went up?
Hydrogen, right?
The good one is mostly on
fluorine;
the bad one,
σ*,
mostly on hydrogen.
And it has that node shown as
an antibonding node;
σ*,
the star means antibonding.
So in OH^-, with its high
energy occupied orbital -- now
wait a second,
why is an unshared pair on
oxygen high energy?
I thought oxygen had a big
nuclear charge,
which would make electrons
stable, not have them be high.
Why is OH^- high?
Obinna, do you have an idea
about that?
What is it about OH^-,
the unshared pair that makes
the electrons unusually high in
energy?
Student:  Because it
didn't mix.
Prof: Can't hear.
Student:  It didn't mix.
Prof: Because it didn't
mix with anything else.
Right?
It's not like a bond that went
down.
We're comparing it to C-H or
C-C σ bonds that
went down in energy.
So even though oxygen started
low, it didn't go down.
Right?
So it's left unusually high.
And there's actually another
reason that this one is
unusually high.
Josh?
Student:  Negative
charge on --
Prof: Negative charge on
oxygen doesn't make electrons
happy.
Okay, so it comes along,
mixes with that.
In the process of putting
electrons into that orbital,
it makes the bond.
But also it makes it
antibonding between hydrogen and
fluorine.
So we draw that second curved
arrow that shows the fluorine
leaving with the electrons,
that it already had most of.
The electrons it leaves with --
not that you can really label
electrons and say this one is
this, this one is this.
But remember,
fluorine mixed with hydrogen
went down.
It already has most of those
electrons that came from
hydrogen.
Now it has them all when it
breaks away.
It breaks away as an ion, F^-.
Okay, and that's an acid-base
reaction;
a more general interpretation
of acid-base,
than just H^+ reacting with
OH^-.
Okay, now let's generalize a
little bit further.
So notice that besides creating
a new bond, which would happen
with H^+, mixing the HOMO with
this LUMO can break a bond --
right?
-- if the LUMO,
shown there,
has an antibonding node.
Putting in electrons means that
those electrons will be more
stable if fluorine moves away.
Right?
So you not only make a bond,
you also break a bond.
So it's a make-and-break
situation;
whereas H^+ plus OH^- is just a
make situation.
Okay, now let's look at F-CH_3.
Right?
And look at the orbital,
and I'm going to superimpose on
it the corresponding LUMO of
F-CH_3.
Watch it change.
The carbon-fluorine bond is
longer than the carbon-hydrogen
bond.
So it moved away.
But the shape,
especially around the fluorine,
is almost identical.
I'll back up and do the change
again.
Right?
So it's going to have very
similar properties to what H-F
did.
So if I move it over,
you see it's going to be
attacked by something coming
here to overlap with that
orbital.
Some high HOMO will mix with
the low LUMO.
And here we show OH^- doing it.
And then what will happen?
Remember, we have this
antibonding node here.
What happens when electrons go
into that orbital?
Kate?
Student:  It breaks the
bond.
Prof: Kate?
Student:  It breaks.
The fluorine is going --
Prof: Yes,
the fluorine will take
electrons and move away,
like that.
Right?
So we get fluoride and
methanol.
Right?
And this reaction,
which we'll study at the
beginning of next semester --
and we'll mention a little bit
more as we go along this
semester,
but systematically we'll talk
about it next semester --
is called SN2 Substitution.
But notice, it's,
from the point of view of
orbitals, exactly the same
make-and-break situation that
you had with OH^- reacting with
H-F.
It's the same reaction,
just the names have been
changed.
Right?
So you could,
in fact, have called the
reaction of OH^- with H-F,
you could've called that a
substitution.
It could've been SN2
Substitution.
The difference would be that
the atom on which the
substitution takes place,
the one that gets attacked and
then loses the F^-,
is hydrogen rather than carbon.
So you could call both
reactions substitution,
or you could call them both
acid-base reactions.
Right?
So that's the way sciences,
as I said last time,
progress, by seeing generality,
where things were thought to be
different before.
Okay, so we have these two
reactions, acid-base reaction,
SN2 Substitution.
What would happen if we had
ethyl fluoride,
sometimes known as ethanol --
improperly labeled -- right?
-- earlier today.
Okay, so that's the LUMO of
ethanol .
Now that doesn't look exactly
like the LUMO we just calculated
of ethanol .
But remember it was the LUMO+3.
Wasn't it that we found?
It was either plus two or plus
-- it was plus three wasn't it?
The LUMO+3, remember,
had this characteristic,
that it's a favorable mixture
of two simple pairwise orbitals.
That one is what?
What's that orbital,
if you just saw that?
Student:
>
Prof: Josh?
Student:  It's the same
thing as the other one.
Prof: Ah-ha,
it's the same thing as up
there.
Right?
It's σ* C-H,
instead of C-F.
Well it's certainly
σ*,
but it's of H-C,
not of F-C.
Right?
Everybody got that?
So but it's σ*,
that's the important thing.
It's the antibonding
combination, σ*
C-H.
Okay, and what's the other
thing that goes into this LUMO,
or actually the LUMO+3?
It's this.
What's that? Right?
Angela?
Student:  It's the
>
Prof: Can you give it a
name?
Student:  It's the
σ* of
>
Prof: If you name just
two atoms, what is it?
Speak up loudly so everybody
can hear.
Student:  σ*
C-F.
Prof: σ*
Everybody see that?
Okay, and I say it's the
favorable mixture of these two,
because they're put together so
as to be bonding between them.
Right?
So there were two vacant
orbitals, σ* C-F
and σ*C-H,
and they mixed,
and the favorable combination,
where they overlapped favorably
between those two,
is the one we're looking at.
It's still vacant,
it's an unoccupied molecular
orbital.
But that's the one we're
looking at here.
Okay, now how should it react?
Well that one looks like the
top right, except that the
colors are changed.
Right?
So how about doing SN2
substitution?
Now Russell cringed when I did
that.
What's wrong with doing SN2
substitution?
Student:  We have to get
a favorable overlap with --
Prof: Ah-ha!
what's hidden here is that bit.
It's going to be hard to
overlap with the blue on top,
without having an unfavorable
overlap with the red on the
bottom.
So there's another way you
could do it.
You could attack here -- right?
-- and get a big orbital,
a big lobe, all of the same
sign.
So there you're going to get
good overlap.
So might it do that?
So there are two possibilities.
It could do the same as the
top, it could do SN2
substitution,
or it could put electrons into
this LUMO by attacking from this
second arrow position.
And how do you know which one
it does?
Students:  Experiments.
Prof: You do experiment.
So this is lore, right?
And when we get to studying
these reactions systematically,
you'll see that both
things can happen.
They're both possibilities,
and you can make little tweaks
in solvent or base and things
like that,
what HOMO you're using,
that'll make it go a little
more one way or a little more
the other.
But that, of course,
takes time to do all the
experiments and to hear about
them.
But anyhow, there are these two
possibilities.
Now let's suppose it does the
second one.
Now how did I set it up so that
that would be favorable?
I didn't use the true LUMO of
the lowest energy,
of the molecule,
which I just calculated for you
at the beginning of class.
What I did was use that LUMO+3,
but made it the LUMO.
And the way I made it the LUMO
was to stretch bonds.
I stretched the C-H bond and I
stretched the C-F bond.
Right?
And then if I -- in this
particular phase of vibration of
the atoms, this one is in fact,
the LUMO.
Okay, now why did I want to
show you this?
Look what happens if you do
that bottom thing.
Okay, so we bring OH^- up,
and the electrons go into this
and make a bond between H and O.
But there's a node here,
that antibonding node.
What does that mean,
if you put electrons into this
orbital?
Lexy, what do you say?
Student:  It'll break.
Prof: It'll break where?
Student:
>
Prof: Between the
hydrogen and the carbon.
Okay, so we're going to --
we'll draw a second curved arrow
that shows those electrons
pulling out.
Okay?
Now where do they go?
Look here, there's an atomic
orbital node there.
That's not an antibonding node
because it's the node of the
p orbitals on the
carbons.
Everybody see that that's not
antibonding?
Because it doesn't go between
the atoms, it goes through the
atoms.
So, in fact,
if you look at that blue and
red lobe in the middle,
they're a little bit distorted.
But what do they look like?
If you look just at the red and
blue in the middle?
Lucas?
Student:  p
orbitals.
Prof: Not p.
Greek.
Student:  Oh π.
Prof: It's the
π orbital,
made up of 2p orbitals;
the p orbital of the
carbon on the top,
carbon on the bottom.
And you put electrons in that
and you get a double bond
between the carbons.
Okay?
Okay, so there's a π
bonding between the carbons.
That means we can draw a second
arrow that takes the electrons
out of the bond that's breaking
and puts them between the two
carbons to make a double bond.
Okay?
But now there's another node in
this LUMO;
there, that antibonding node.
What happens with respect to
that, when we put electrons in
this LUMO?
Rick, what do you say?
Student:  The C is going
to break the bond between the C
and the F.
Prof: The bond between C
and F will break.
How will we draw a curved arrow
to show that?
Student:  You would draw
a curved arrow starting at the C
and ending at the --
Prof: Not starting at
the C.
Which are the electrons that
are leaving?
You start with the electrons
that are changing,
right?
Student:  Yes.
Prof: So where are they,
in this diagram here?
Here, tell me when to stop,
when I hit the electrons?
Student:  Stop.
Prof: Not here.
That's the one that's building
up electrons,
right?
Student:  There?
>
Prof: These are the
electrons that are leaving.
And where do I draw the curved
arrow to, where are they going?
Okay.
On to the F.
So that's what happens.
When the O-H comes up,
you get water,
you get ethylene,
the double bond,
and fluoride.
So this is called,
as you'll see -- just after we
talk about SN2 substitution,
we'll talk about E2
elimination.
Right?
And that's what this reaction
is.
Right?
But that's just an old
category.
Right?
If we want to make it -- what
it is,
is the same kind of HOMO/LUMO
interaction,
except this time we make
two bonds and break
two bonds,
because of where the nodes
were, in the LUMO that was being
attacked.
Right?
There were two antibonding
nodes.
We break two bonds.
Okay, does anybody have a
question about this?
Do you see how it works?
Lucas?
Student:  Why did you
stretch C-H again?
Student:  Why did I do
it?
Because I knew the answer.
I knew that this reaction does
this E2 elimination,
because when I studied organic
chemistry we did E2 elimination
and never talked about orbitals
at all.
Okay?
So I knew where I was going.
I knew what really happened.
So I said, how does that
happen, that this is the orbital
that actually gets attacked?
And it's, in fact,
the LUMO+3.
Right?
Why do the electrons go into
that?
And then I saw that in a
certain phase of vibration of
the molecule,
when this bond is long,
and when this bond is
stretched, then it is the LUMO.
So when the OH is attacking,
the OH^- is attacking,
it's attacking at a time that
those bonds are stretched at the
same time.
Right?
And then they break.
Okay?
It's a little bit of chicken
and the egg as to whether the
electrons going in make them
stretch, or their stretching
allows the electrons to go in.
Right?
But anyhow, I knew what the
answer was,
which you wouldn't have known,
if you had just looked at the
orbitals for the minimum energy
geometry of the molecule.
Okay, now let's look,
let's generalize this to a
complicated, or fairly
complicated, reaction scheme,
at least by our lights.
So three ammonia molecules
react with chlorine.
That's called oxidation of
ammonia,
and it generates hydrazine,
the nitrogen-nitrogen bond,
or actually hydrazinium -- it's
a cation --
chloride, and ammonium chloride.
That looks pretty complicated.
There's a lot of changes going
on.
How does it happen?
Could we figure it out?
I think you can.
Okay, so in the starting
material I want to find a high
HOMO.
Where do I find it?
Sherwin, can you help us?
What do I look -- I want to
find a high HOMO in this
starting material.
The starting materials are
ammonia and the chlorine
molecule.
So what about them could give
you a high, unusually
high-occupied orbital?
Student:  The unmixed
atomic orbital --
Prof: Say it clearly.
Student:  The unmixed
atomic orbital in ammonia.
Prof: Yes,
the unshared pair of ammonia.
Right?
N has a bigger nuclear change
than C.
So you might expect the
electrons to be low in energy.
But it never mixed with
anything, so it didn't go down
to become a σ bond.
So, unshared pair on ammonia.
I'll take that.
Okay.
Now we have to react it with
some -- and unshared pairs are
often denoted n,
little n.
And I actually don't know why
that is.
It'd be fun to find out.
Okay, now we need a low LUMO.
Anybody got an idea for what a
low LUMO might be in this
system?
What kind of things give rise
to low LUMOs?
Student:
Electronegative things.
Prof: Sam?
Student:
Electronegative --
Prof: Electronegative
nuclei.
Right?
Big nuclear charges.
You know, people always say
electronegative,
but that's the cart and the
horse.
Why is something
electronegative?
That means it's a good place
for electrons to go.
Right?
It's because the nuclear charge
is big;
that's what's fundamental.
Okay, where do we find that
here?
Student:  In the
chlorine.
Prof: The chlorine.
Now which orbital,
associated with the chlorines,
is going to be unusually low in
energy?
Does it have a vacant atomic
orbital?
Bear in mind what's -- chlorine
is in the last column,
right?
So it's just missing one
electron.
So a chlorine atom has three
unshared pairs and one odd
electron, which has come with
the other chlorine to make that
bond.
Right?
So after the Cl_2 forms,
where's the vacant orbital?
Anybody see?
We had two chlorines,
each with this odd electron.
They came together and you got
a σ bond.
Where's the low LUMO?
Chris?
Student:  It's going be
like a 4s atomic orbital.
Prof: No.
Kevin?
Student:
σ*.
Prof: σ*,
right?
They each had one electron.
Come together, they went down.
But there was a σ*
that went up.
σ* is usually high
energy, but not in this case
because, as Sam pointed out,
the nuclear charge is big,
so it's low.
So σ* on chlorine.
Okay?
So what kind of reaction are we
going to have?
If we mix σ* of
chlorine with the unshared pair
on nitrogen?
Have you ever seen a reaction
like this before,
where you have a
σ* mixing with an
unshared pair?
Katelyn?
Student:  On the last
slide.
Prof: On the last slide
we saw lots of examples.
Right?
And so Katelyn, what happens?
Tell me how to draw a curved
arrow here.
Student:  The electrons
from the unshared -- no.
Prof: The electrons on
the unshared pair of nitrogen,
that's the high HOMO.
Between what?
Student:  The two Cl's?
Prof: Between the
nitrogen and the chlorine.
They mix with that vacant
orbital.
But the ones in the chlorine,
now that's an antibonding
orbital, σ*,
so a chloride leaves.
So it's exactly the same
reaction, make and break,
that we saw before.
Okay?
So we get ammonium chloride
"chlorammonium"
and Cl^-, plus/minus,
net neutral.
We started neutral,
we're still neutral.
Okay?
And now we have one of the
products, the chloride up above
we have.
Okay, but we also have this
molecule.
Now it has a low LUMO,
so it's reactive.
What is the low LUMO?
Yoonjoo?
Student:  The N-H bond.
Prof: That's not what I
would've said.
It turns out to be right,
but it's not what I would've
said.
There are going to be N-H --
it's got to be vacant,
so what's the name of the
orbital?
Student:
σ*
Prof: σ*
N-H.
Are there any other
σ*s here?
Russell?
Student:  Cl.
Prof: Cl.
Which do you think is going to
be lower, σ* N-Cl
or σ* N-H?
Kevin?
Student:  I would guess
N-Cl.
Student:  I would have
too.
So the lowest LUMO is for some
HOMO.
Now what are we going to use
for a HOMO?
We have to have another reagent
for this to react with.
Well fortunately that
σ*_ N-H
is what we're actually going to
use.
Okay?
So the high HOMO.
We had three ammonias to begin
with.
So we can use another one;
same deal again, right?
So the best reaction,
I think, would be for the
unshared pair to attack the
chlorine;
at least that's something that
you could imagine.
If that happened,
what would the product be?
If NH_3 attacked Cl,
it would make an NH_3^(-)Cl
bond, and lose what?
What Russell?
Student:  NH_3.
Prof: So what about it?
Student:  That's what it
could make there.
Prof: It could happen
'til the cows come home,
but the product is the same as
the starting material,
and no one cares.
It would exchange which
nitrogen is attached to the
chlorine.
But unless you label them with
isotopes or something,
you'd have no way of knowing.
So that probably does happen,
or at least I suspect it
happens some of the time.
Right?
But you don't care.
So now we resort to Yoonjoo's
suggestion that we'll use a
different one so we get a
different product.
Okay?
So we'll attack the N-H bond.
Now Corey, tell us how to draw
a curved arrow to show this.
Where's the curved arrow going
to start?
Student:  On the lone
pair.
Prof: On the lone pair
of the nitrogen.
And where will it end?
Student:  In between the
N and the H.
Prof: In between the N
and the H.
And what else will happen?
Student:  The bond will
break.
Prof: Which bond?
What's going to take off with
the electrons?
Can you see?
Nothing.
Well, that is,
what you lose -- it becomes an
unshared pair on nitrogen.
N was N^+, right?
Now it gets the electrons that
formerly it was sharing with H.
So it ends on nitrogen. Right?
So there's the product.
And now I've highlighted in
blue another one of the ultimate
products.
Right?
So now we've made ammonium
chloride.
Right?
We've made one of the products.
But we need the other one.
But we have this product,
from the second reaction.
Now, what do we have for a low
LUMO here?
Nate, do you have an idea?
You have only σ
bonds, and an unshared pair on
nitrogen, and three unshared
pairs on chlorine.
Right?
But those are all occupied.
What's a vacant orbital here?
What kind of vacant orbitals do
you get in molecules that have
only σ bonds?
Student:  The p
orbitals.
Prof: No,
the p orbitals are
filled with electrons here.
Right?
So they're not vacant.
Student:  You get a
σ* then.
You get σ*.
Prof: σ*.
Which σ -- you
have N-H σ* and you
have N-Cl_
σ*.
Which one do you think is lower?
Student:  The last time
it was the N-H.
Prof: No, it wasn't.
The one that reacted last time
was the N-H, but it wasn't the
lowest.
The N-Cl was the lowest.
Why didn't we care last time?
Because the product,
when that reacted,
you got the starting material
back.
So who cared? Right?
So this time it's the N-Cl.
Right?
What's the high HOMO we're
going to use?
Student:  NH_3.
Prof: Ah. Wilson?
Student:  The NH_3,
we still --
Prof: Ah,
we got a third one up there
still.
Right?
So bring it in.
And there are the curved
arrows, and there's the product.
Hydrazine -- hydrazinium,
it's got a proton and there's a
plus charge -- hydrochloride,
hydrazinium chloride.
Right?
So that is the last product.
So we've done it.
So there are three of these
reactions that take place,
three cycles of make and break.
And notice the difference among
them, right?
It's always NH_3 that attacks.
But first it attacks chlorine,
then it attacks hydrogen,
then it attack nitrogen.
But it's the same reaction we
talked about on the previous
slide, right?
Make and break.
Okay, now we're going to look
at four functional groups:
The C double bond O,
carbonyl;
amide;
carboxylic acid;
and alkyl lithium.
And after that,
we'll have done what we wanted
to do about functional groups.
Although it will still be in
your court to do functional
groups,
because you have these Wikis,
to do the same kind of analysis
on the functional groups that
we're doing here,
on these four functional groups.
And those are due Thursday.
And almost all of them are
signed up for.
There are just a few more to do.
So if you want a choice,
get there quickly,
because I'll assign them this
afternoon,
I think, because we're almost
at the end,
and I have to make sure
everything gets covered.
Okay, so the carbonyl group,
C=O double bond.
This is probably the most
important functional group in
organic chemistry.
Why is it so important?
(a) Because it's strong,
so it gives stable compounds,
low energy compounds.
So you have a lot of carbonyl
groups.
But, paradoxically,
it's not only strong,
but it reacts easily.
So it's easy to make things
from carbonyls.
Okay, that sounds
contradictory,
that it should be both stable
and reactive;
but it is, and we'll see why.
So let's look at the shape of
the frontier orbitals.
There are six valence electron
pairs in formaldehyde,
shown here from the side.
And we could show the molecular
orbitals, right?;
the Chladni style,
plum-pudding molecular
orbitals.
So the lowest one is 1s,
or 2s if you want to
count the core.
Right?
Which is mostly on the oxygen,
a little bit on carbon.
And then there's the
2p_x, 2_y_
and 2p_z,
as plum pudding orbitals.
And then there's this 3s
orbital and this
3d_xy_ orbital.
But let's look a little more
closely at that,
from the point of view of
pairwise interactions.
What things interacted with one
another to give these?
So let's do the kind of
pairwise mixing we've been
talking about.
There's the HOMO,
an older style picture of the
HOMO, the one that's called
3d_xy,
on the right.
And this is drawn at a -- it
was based on a different
calculation and it's drawn at a
different contour level.
But you can see what it -- what
is it mostly,
the HOMO?
If you had to give a simple
name to it, what would you call
it, if you neglected the little
tiny pieces on the right?
What does it look like?
Sherwin?
Student:  p
orbital on oxygen.
Prof: It's a p
orbital on oxygen,
an unshared pair of oxygen,
mostly,
although it is mixed a little
bit with something else.
Now, to see what else it's
mixed with, we can go down the
list by three steps and look at
that orbital,
the one that's called
2p_y.
Because it also has that little
bit of oxygen in it,
but more of the other stuff.
Now let's look at nodes in
these things.
There's nodes that are nodes of
atomic orbitals,
of the oxygen and of the
carbon;
they bisect the molecule.
Those don't have to do with
bonding.
Right?
But the one on the top also has
an antibonding node.
Can you see where that is?
Shai?
Student:  Between the
carbon and the oxygen.
Prof: Between the carbon
and the oxygen,
there's an antibonding node.
So this is a favorable and an
unfavorable combination of,
in the front,
oxygen, the front left is
oxygen,
and in the back right is some
sort of C-H bond.
So those molecular orbitals are
made by combining 2p of
oxygen with σ
C-H;
in fact two σ C-Hs.
Okay?
Now, which one is lower in
energy, the unshared pair on
oxygen, or σ
C-H?
Notice that the oxygen has
something going for it,
which is a big nuclear charge,
but the C-H has something going
for it,
which is the bonding of the
C-H, which lowered it from where
carbon and hydrogen atomic
orbitals would be.
Which one is lower,
the 2p of oxygen or
σ C-H?
Which wins?
Can you tell by looking at this?
Angela?
Student: σ
C-H_ is lower
because the one on the bottom
has less nodes than the one on
the top.
Prof: Right.
The favorable combination,
which looks mostly like the
lower one, looks mostly like
C-H;
and the unfavorable one,
the one that went up,
looks mostly like O.
So clearly the σ
C-H_ is lower in
energy than the 2p of
oxygen.
Okay, now let's look at the
LUMO, up on top,
in the plum pudding column,
right?
And here's another version of
that.
And you can see what it is.
It's made up of a p
orbital on oxygen and a p
orbital on carbon.
That's an atomic orbital node.
It has nothing to do with the
bonding.
But there is an antibonding
node between them.
Right?
So this is the π*
orbital;
not the occupied one but the
vacant orbital,
the LUMO.
Right?
There's poor overlap because
it's π*;
that's why it's unusually low.
And it's also unusually low
compared to C,
C-C, because it's got an oxygen
in it, a high nuclear charge.
So poor energy match;
2p O_ is lower
in energy than the 2p of
carbon.
Okay?
And there -- we're going to
show this on the next slide,
those two -- but the top one,
you see,
is the favorable combination of
2p O and 2p_z;
the one of which this is the
unfavorable combination.
But it's not the HOMO, right?
The HOMO is that unshared pair
on oxygen, which is the dominant
thing in 3d_xy.
Okay, so now let's look at
these.
There's the C=O π
bonding orbital.
Now which one should that be
big on?
Don't look at it.
Which one should the
π -- the favorable
combination of p on
oxygen and p on carbon,
which should it be big on?
There's p on oxygen,
p on carbon,
they mix;
π overlap,
not too much overlap,
so they don't go so much up and
down.
But what does this,
the bonding one,
what does it mostly look like?
Student: Oxygen.
Prof: It should look
mostly like oxygen.
When you look at this picture
it doesn't look that way.
That's because of which contour
we drew.
Because oxygen holds its
electrons closer.
So by the time you get out to a
certain low --
so you get through most of the
electron density of oxygen,
as you go out one contour by
the other of the onion,
that's the oxygen;
there are more electrons inside.
So indeed it does have more
electron density on oxygen than
it does on carbon,
but it doesn't show well in
this particular contour.
Anyhow, that's the π
bonding.
And this one is a different
unshared pair on Oxygen.
And that's mostly a
p-rich,
hybrid atomic orbital of
oxygen, but it's got a little
bit of the C-H bonding and it's
a favorable combination;
there's a little bit of
favorable bonding between there.
Okay, but the nodes that you
see in this, in neither orbital
are the nodes antibonding.
They're always the nodes that
go through atoms.
They're part of atomic orbitals.
These are bonding orbitals,
the occupied ones,
as you expect them to be.
Okay, but now let's look at
that LUMO, that vacant orbital,
the π* orbital.
What direction should a high
energy HOMO approach this,
in order to mix with it?
So it has to get good overlap
as it comes in,
and not run into the other
nuclei, or the other electron
density associated with other
orbitals on the way in.
Okay, well here are three
possibilities.
You could attack from within
the plane, from the oxygen end;
from within the plane toward
the carbon;
or from straight up,
halfway between carbon and
oxygen.
How do those look as ways for
an orbital to come in and
overlap?
Suppose it came from the right.
Suppose you had a big ball,
like OH^-, coming in along that
arrow from the right?
You going to get good overlap?
What would you call that
situation?
Student:  Orthogonal.
Prof: Orthogonal, right?
So you're not going to get
overlap -- how about if you come
from the left,
the arrow on the left?
Student:  It's also --
Prof: That's also going
to be orthogonal.
How about if you come from the
top?
It's not precisely orthogonal,
but it's pretty close to
orthogonal.
You have both positive and
negative overlap.
So in fact none of those are
good.
Now here are two other
possibilities.
You could attack the oxygen on
the top, or you could attack the
carbon on the top.
Which of those do you think
looks better?
Student:  Carbon.
Prof: Carbon.
Why?
Angela?
Student:  It's bigger.
Prof: Because it's
bigger.
Okay, so I'd say that one's
smaller, so forget that.
So come in from the carbon.
Okay, so here's a better
drawing of that orbital.
And we want to come in actually
from that direction,
at a certain angle;
not 90º,
with respect to the
oxygen-carbon bond.
Now why come in from that angle?
Why not come straight down on
top?
Student:  You get less
overlap with the oxygen.
Prof: There are the
nodes.
Right?
This is furthest from the node.
So you can overlap the nodes
you want to overlap with,
without getting near the blue
ones.
Right?
So you should come in at a
certain angle.
Now, there's a prediction.
Is it true?
So what we're going to do this
is rotate this so the
orientation corresponds to a
graph,
that appeared in a paper by
Dunitz and Bürgi in 1983,
when they were analyzing this.
Now what did they do?
They looked at X-ray crystal
structures of many,
many crystals that had both a
nitrogen in it --
so the unshared pair -- and
they had a carbon-oxygen double
bond.
And they looked to see,
in many, many different
structures,
how those atoms are arranged,
because they must be arranged
in a low energy way next to one
another.
Okay?
That's the way they would pack
in the crystal.
Okay, so now how is this
diagram made?
Well notice that the carbon and
oxygen are drawn there.
So that's the carbon and
oxygen, and they're made --
so all these different
crystals, some have the group
oriented this way,
some this way,
some this way.
So you rotate all those
crystals so that their carbons
are superimposed with one
another, in all the structures;
the carbons are all there,
and the oxygen is along this
particular line,
which lies in the plane of the
screen.
Right?
And then there are things
attached to it,
which are R groups;
an R group -- that is whatever
group, hydrogen or carbon or
something -- attached to the
carbon.
There's one in front of the
plane and one behind the plane.
Okay?
So we rotate all these
different structures around that
carbon-oxygen bond.
So those things are all one
hiding the other one;
the R in front hides the R
behind.
And now we look,
with that orientation,
to see where the nitrogen is
nearby.
And those dots up on the top
show in many different
structures, labeled A,
B, C, D, E, F,
G, H, I -- no J -- K,
L.
Okay?
In all those different
structures where's the nitrogen?
So in structure G,
a particular compound,
the nitrogen is where the blue
dot is on top.
The carbon is -- all the
carbons are always there.
That's the origin, right?
Here.
The oxygens are along this line.
So the oxygen is along that
line and at that position,
that distance.
And the R groups are bent down
a little bit from being planar.
One is here and the other one
is behind.
Okay?
Okay, but now let's go G,
H, I, K, L.
G, H, I, K, L.
Do you see what happens?
Let's go back.
K, I, H, G.
These are five different
crystal structures.
But look again.
So the nitrogen comes down,
from one structure to the next.
What happens to the R's,
as the nitrogen comes down?
Student:  They move away.
Prof: Right,
the R's bend down.
So the nitrogen -- the carbon,
pardon me, in the middle,
becomes pyramidal rather than
planar.
Back up.
What happens to the oxygen as
we do this?
There's G, H, I, K, L.***Right?
Okay, so here's what happened.
The nitrogen moves down,
the Rs bend down,
and the oxygen moves away.
Why does the oxygen move away
from the carbon,
from a theoretical,
orbital point of view?
Where are you putting electrons?
Where are you putting the
electrons here,
when you put them into this
LUMO?
Into an orbital that's
antibonding between carbon and
oxygen.
So the oxygen stretches away
from the carbon.
Kevin?
Student:  On the right
side of the screen,
the length units,
what is that?
Prof: That's
Ångstroms.
So it's zero is the origin;
that's where the carbon is.
And there's one Ångstrom,
1,2, 3.
So they start three -- the
nitrogen starts three
Ångstroms from the carbon,
and as it comes in it gets to
be within about 1.6 or
something.
And I forget.
I'm guessing that an actual
bond between that nitrogen and
carbon is probably the order of
1.3 or something;
I'm not actually sure it is.
So they haven't quite bonded.
But it's following the pathway
of reaction, when you look at a
lot of these different
structures.
Okay?
Now that angle,
110º, along the path that
they follow, is called the
Bürgi-Dunitz Angle;
that's the guys who did the
paper, Hans-Beat Bürgi and
Jack Dunitz in Switzerland.
So there is a bunch of what we
might consider snapshots of a
reaction actually taking place.
And you can see that there's a
well-defined angle from which
the nitrogen approaches that
LUMO, as it mixes with it.
Now, resonance is
intramolecular HOMO/LUMO mixing.
We've looked here at
intermolecular,
which is reaction.
But next time we'll go on to
this slide and look at the
analogous thing that happens
within a molecule.
Okay.